Captain Rambo
what the hell are you doing
entering the jump Point perimeter
I'm gonna get you some readings Fury
looks good well not that floating head
but the picture quality looks good
[Music]
Miss Marvel
where's Captain Rambo
[Music]
anything with music Galactic by the
Beastie Boys
got my heartstrings and obviously
they're tied in Happily with the ending
of his Marvel
so this was the post-credits scene
[Music]
okay so our powers are entangled
I can manipulate don't tell Will Smith
daughter wherever you were
it looks so right so far you know
I heard bad things behind the scenes but
[Music]
we're a team oh no no no we're not we're
not a team
I'm gonna say it I'm pleasantly
surprised yeah I think it looks alright
okay so that's a trailer uh let me know
below exactly what you thought I wanted
to do a fully in-depth breakdown but
unfortunately we've just been getting
swamped recently obviously we've just
had the big long weekend in England
um Friday was off for a lot of people in
England and Monday as well so my editors
weren't working and we're just getting a
pile of trailers we had Blue Beetle uh
into the spider-verse Bobby uh this one
obviously Ahsoka and unfortunately I
wasn't able to cover that last one so I
just thought for this um that I'd do a
quick reaction so you guys at least can
get my thoughts on it and you can stop
being like why is he not covering this
is it because he hates women and no that
might be true
um it's just unfortunately we haven't
had time yet don't clip that on YouTube
as well and and make a Twitter video
where I say I hate women I love Captain
Marvel and Ms Marvel I've got comics
yeah which I must love them if I have
bought Comics I've taken great care of
um so yeah let me know your thoughts
below and I just thought I'd give a
quick explanation of why we're kind of
all over the place I don't normally like
doing reactions because I want to give
you know more of my in-depth thoughts
but I just wanted to go over the trailer
make it look like I'm not giving you
guys nothing and avoiding this because
of uh reasons that some people have
invented in their heads and yet we'll go
into the breakdown and uh see in that
bit thanks okay so they start off on
this um saber station which I'm guessing
is a sword
basically it looks like it's owned by
sword it might be part of Shield as well
obviously they do Intergalactic things
um and Monica Rambo as part of them as
well so maybe maybe that's why she's
kind of drifting into space and doing
this thing they've got a nice little
floating head there inside the space
suit but another thing bit of attention
to detail you might notice that she's
got the little gold visor on the top now
that blocks out the Sun so uh very very
clever looks like she's investigating a
hex point or something
um and basically through this trailer it
seems like when they use their powers
um these three it switches their bodies
um which is why later on
it seems like Ms Marvel goes to show her
powers and then it switches out yeah
switches out with Carol I was Bloody
right that's a bloody Theory time
YouTube
um so yeah you kind of have the Nick
view you're trying to figure out what's
going on you don't really get a massive
scale of who my dog's boggling in the
background so sorry if you can hear that
I'll kick him or I'll kick off with him
later we've got the doorbell ringing as
well right we're back I don't know what
the hell I was saying but something
about the power switching and then
you've got hex points as well
um guessing that Monica switches with
Carol here and that's why she's out in
space and then you've got the cree as
well nice blue screen I think it's the
cree it looks like they're Warriors from
um at least the way they would have
picked it in Loki and then we cut to Ms
Marvel's room this was the post-credits
scene of Ms Marvel
um yeah
just kind of I'm guessing that was
filmed specifically for that show and
then it pulled they're pulling it into
the movie so you've got the Iron Man
helmet and her computer and stuff
and then just looking about the room
we're kind of wondering what's going on
you've got the great Marvel Studios swap
it does a little body swap itself and
then Kamala Khan's family there's not
really loads of stuff here you've
obviously got gooseback the cat I do
believe later on that you also see
flirtkins
it might have just been normal kittens
but it looked like flagons to me don't
trust them kittens and yeah you've got
them kind of swapping powers and I like
this shot here where they're clearly
fighting a villain and uh they swap the
powers out so that they change places to
avoid getting hit that's quite a good
little good little fight scene
you know what I thought it was all right
I'm sure you can tell we've got Brie
back look at those abs
um yeah and lots of things going on here
nice obviously photons kind of flying
through the air there I'm guessing that
she's swept with Carol uh you've got
this wedding thing
there were rumors that Captain Marvel
gets married at one point in the movie
so I'm guessing that's what we're seeing
and yeah just lots of fighting stuff you
know it's not a super in-depth Deep dive
but I think it looks all right I'm gonna
get slated on the internet I know I've
got a loyal following who don't really
like Captain Marvel that much but I
thought it was all right okay and that
sums up the whole thing I hope you
enjoyed the video you know if you did
like these more off the cuff things
um maybe if I don't have time to do a
breakdown I'll do something like this
instead you know I really really wanted
to get to that Ahsoka trailer but
unfortunately just the way things kind
of build up we just didn't have the time
to do it so things like this
um are a lot easier for me um I can just
pump them out quickly and you know if
you think that's good enough for the
channel you know we do try and kind of
keep a certain level of quality here but
if you think that's good enough amongst
all the other trash that we do then let
me know below and if it's trailers where
I I don't really think I'm gonna have
time to do a massive in-depth 20 minute
long breakdown then I'm more than happy
to do these in 15 minutes so if if
you're happy with that let me know below
if you're not I totally understand but
yeah thanks for sticking through the
video I've been Paul I'll see you next
time now if you want something else to
watch you've got a breakdown linked on
the screen right now one of our better
trailer reactions so definitely head
over there right after this huge thank
you again for sticking through the video
I hope you enjoyed it we know we had a
bit of fun with it it's nice just to see
my reactions sometime to these trailers
and yeah let me know below exactly what
you think huge thank you for clicking
this you take care peace